[Musique]
c'est vrai je suis resté 15 ans sans
domicile fixe
alors vous imaginez bien que si je suis
resté aussi longtemps sur domicile fixe
c'est que j'ai dû manquer de cadre bien
avant
alors quand je suis né sur décision de
justice j'ai été placé à la DASS puis
dans une pouponnière puis dans une
famille d'accueil puis dans une autre
famille d'accueil et puis dans un foyer
puis dans un autre foyer 15 ans
je suis exclu du système scolaire
c'était le cadre le plus solide que
j'avais depuis mon enfance
entre 15 ans et 18 ans je suis devenu ce
qu'on appelle une adolescente
errante
et à 18 ans
ma prise en charge était terminée et la
rue me tendait les bras
grand ouvert
alors je vais vous donner
oui parce que ce que j'ai oublié de vous
dire c'est pas parce qu'on est à la rue
qu'on a pas de cadre même si la société
ce que j'appelle les inclus chaque fois
te pointes bien du doigt comme quoi tu
es hors cadre
alors voilà ça c'est la vie de mon pote
Rachid donc à 6h il se lève enfin en
fait il se lève surtout pour aller se
recoucher pour aller dormir dans un
accueil de jour par exemple parce que la
nuit voilà c'est très dangereux d'être à
la rue que qu'on se conçoit un homme ou
une femme après bon il va apprendre son
petit déjeuner après il fait un peu la
Manche enfin après voilà vous voyez un
peu vous voyez ça c'est la vie c'est une
journée entière d'un le fixe
oui on n'a pas du boulot
bon attendez par contre moi j'ai jamais
fait la manche ah non elle était pas
question moi mon cadre c'était pas
celui-ci alors pas question
le lundi par exemple je repérais une
femme bah oui faut dire ce qui est les
femmes c'est quand même plus sympa non
et
je prenais mon courage à deux mains elle
courait je corrige corrige
mon
train mes enfants m'attendent
et hop 10 euros merci Madame
le mardi je suis tombé dans les pommes
alcool Médoc pompier direction hôpital
c'est peinard de dormir à l'hôpital
personne te fait chier et surtout tu
fais chier personne avec cette technique
j'ai fait tous les hôpitaux de la ville
le mercredi j'allais chez Tati piquer
des slips
et mine de rien je sortais
et comme j'avais jamais rien à faire ben
je faisais toujours semblant d'attendre
quelqu'un et vous pouvez essayer les
filles même en 2023 ça marche encore
mais qu'est-ce qu'il fait c'est pas
possible quoi
non mais jamais à l'heure ce type
mademoiselle je pense qu'il vous a posé
un lapin
je vous propose un petit Kawa et hop
deux heures au chaud merci monsieur
bon au début je tombais toujours sur des
mecs qui sortaient de prison juste avant
d'y retourner
alors du coup
je suis passé dans le papy oh les papis
c'est génial une petite caresse sur le
front ils sont tout gai
il voulait toujours m'emmener en
vacances mais moi je vais pas le temps
alors après je suis passé au Costa
cravate
le soir du jeudi du lundi au jeudi les
boîtes de nuit c'est gratuit pour les
filles
vous pouvez essayer encore ça marche les
bon attention
j'allais pas pour danser pour dormir
et le vendredi je dormais chez celui que
j'avais rencontré le lundi
le samedi c'est celui du mardi
et le dimanche chez celui du mercredi
et les jours de relâche ah bah oui des
fois il y avait des jours de relaxe
mais moche je me faisais le plus moche
possible et je me tapais les lignes de
métro de bout en bout pour pas commun
mais
ça marche
vous avez vu il y a pas que les gens qui
bossent qui ont un planning
19 ans arrive
ouais j'ai pris quand même quelques
risques pendant ma rue sèche
je me retrouve sous tutelle de juge
alors là je peux vous assurer que du
cadre j'en ai eu du cadre
je parlerai même de recadrage
j'étais obligé de voir le juge une fois
par mois
un éducateur deux fois par semaine et en
psychiatre trois fois par semaine
et ça jusqu'à 21 ans
mais à 21 ans ma prise en charge était
terminée donc rebelote je me retrouve à
la rue mais sans le savoir
j'avais appris des choses
bon
me voilà parti au hasard des rues à la
rencontre des nombreux réinsérateurs
vous savez les gens qui réinsèrent aller
travailleur sociaux quoi il y en a dans
la salle
attention
tu as par exemple je pourrais vous dire
j'ai rencontré ah oui il y a plein il y
a plein de profils la traditionnelle
vous ne rentrez pas dans le cadre du
cadre mais en revanche si vous apportez
le dos qui remplissez le programme grâce
vous glissez dans le programme
22 ans trop tard
des enfants non dommage
vous ne dépendez pas du dispositif
cloque mais du plan bling bling
en principe tu fais oui de la tête et tu
repars
je pourrais aussi vous parler de la
rassurance
salut on se tutoie
t'inquiète je m'arrange pour tout ça au
chaud tu sais mes bouts tu gagnes plus
que moi
t'inquiète on se fait la bise
la bise mais oh on n'a pas gardé les
cartons ensemble
ah non mais seul
alors elle
oui mademoiselle
ah moi personnellement je bois plus une
goutte à l'école
que du champagne
oui c'est une nouvelle technique un sas
pour décrocher
vous vous voulez arrêter de boire
mais
buvez du champagne
pas de travail pas de champagne
mais mesdemoiselles attendez vous
connaissez la différence entre un
poivron du bitume et un alcoolo comme la
thune
et ben c'est l'étiquette sur la
bouteille
et pourtant eux excusez-moi là j'étais
entre les mains de personnes qui avaient
un cadre de vie
et non mais heureusement attendez
heureusement
il y a une femme un jour qui m'a tendu
la main en échange je devais garder ses
enfants
et j'avais un petit toit au dessus de ma
tête qui faisait 10 mètres carrés il y
avait pas de lavabo ni de douche
mais
je sentais
que c'est 4 murs
je sentais une sécurité
parce que après tout un cadre ça sert à
ça
être sécurisant et puis en plus cette
femme qui était très bourgeoise m'a
invité dans son cadre
et mais ce cadre il me faisait peur elle
me parlait de livre me parler d'aller au
musée
et elle elle m'a accepté telle que
j'étais parce que quand elle m'a
accueilli chez elle je prenais encore du
crack
et ensemble
nos cadres sont mélangés ce sont mixés
et pendant
un an et demi nous avons
j'ai envie de dire grandir ensemble
pas de la même façon évidemment
et
ça a été en tout cas une histoire très
magique d'ailleurs elle en a fait un
livre qui s'appelle sans moi qui a été
invest-seller et qui raconte comment
deux cadres se rencontrent de cadre qui
n'ont pas du tout la même vie
et elle a travers moi elle a appris
beaucoup de choses et ça l'aurait jamais
imaginé elle me l'a dit bien plus tard
évidemment
et puis
c'est une femme
voilà chaque fois que je fais une
conférence ou que je
devant des personnes comme vous je suis
obligé de lui prêter un bel hommage
parce que c'est rare de nos jours que
les cadres se rencontrent que les cadres
puissent se construire ensemble
et
si je vous le dis c'est que
aujourd'hui
alors
évidemment j'ai eu ce toit
cette petite chambre de bonne
mais vous savez il y a quel âge de 44
ans
quand j'ai eu mon premier toit
que j'ai vraiment compris ce que ça
voulait dire un toit mais quand vous
avez passé plus de 15 ans sans domicile
fixe que vous avez passé de foyer
d'urgence en foyer d'hébergement dans
des foyers avec des personnes très
malades des personnes Alzheimer le jour
où vous avez un toit mais vous comprenez
rien et tout le monde va vous dire mais
enfin depuis le temps que tu le voulais
ton toi tu l'as ça y est maintenant tu
vas pouvoir avancer dans la vie mais
vous avez pas me croire j'ai fait une
dépression de six mois
et là je peux vous expliquer
j'avais la clé
et au moment de mettre la clé dans la
serrure
pouvais pas je remettais la clé dans ma
poche et je retourne dehors dans un parc
rejoindre mes potes sans domicile et
véridique
alors Marie m'a dit écoutez Lina c'est
pas possible personne ne me comprenait
personne Marie m'a dit déjà tu vas
retourner voir le psychiatre on sait ce
que j'ai fait
et pendant 6 mois j'ai dormi chez Marie
je suis retourné voir le psychiatre et
vous allez rigoler enfin moi j'ai rigolé
grave enfin la psychiatre me dit mais
enfin mademoiselle Dumont je ne sais pas
vous n'avez pas pensé à le décorer mais
elle dans son cadre oui mais dans le
mien moi j'ai jamais je sais pas partout
où j'ai habité on m'a jamais donné la
possibilité de mettre une photo sur un
mur on m'a jamais même dit achète une
chaise achète un lit
donc
je me suis dit mais elle est folle cette
psychiatre puis en fait au fur et à
mesure de mes séances évidemment j'ai
compris que oui peut-être que je
pourrais m'approprier ce nouveau cadre
ça n'a pas été facile je peux vous le
dire parce que ce cadre j'avais
tellement du mal à me l'approprier c'est
que du coup j'ai invité tous les
sans-abri chez moi
alors là je vous raconte pas un c'est
pas possible la police aux fesses parce
qu'évidemment mes copains ils disaient
qu'ils habitaient chez moi enfin bref je
vous passe les détails et du coup j'ai
été obligé de redéménager parce que
j'étais en danger voilà j'ai été menacé
de mort et ensuite donc aujourd'hui
j'habite un petit studio de 19 mètres
carrés et au début j'avais mis une
pancarte je n'invite plus de connu chez
moi
ouais je vous jure que c'est vrai et
maintenant ça va je me fais plus
violence bon en tout cas voilà pourquoi
je vous raconte tout ça pourquoi
l'importance de changer
d'échanger nos cadres parce
qu'aujourd'hui mais jamais j'aurais
imaginé ça vous vous rendez compte des
politiques que vous connaissez sûrement
aujourd'hui ont pété leurs cadres pour
venir dans mon cadre et pour mieux
comprendre qu'est-ce que c'est que le
sans-abrisme j'ai écrit un rapport
contre le sans-abrisme des femmes qui
est sorti en 2020 j'ai écrit un livre
longtemps dehors j'ai habité dehors j'ai
Flammarion 18 euros en vente partout
même à Metz
je travaille avec le ministre du
Logement je travaille avec l'adjoint au
logement la ville de Paris je travaille
pour la région Île-de-France
mais ça c'est incroyable
personne j'aurais jamais imaginé que des
politiques un jour viendrai me chercher
et me dire au secours et donc je suis
très engagé actuellement
politiquement mais ce que je voudrais
dire surtout
c'est qu'en fait l'important on s'en
fout du cadre enfin on s'en fout et on
s'en fout pas parce qu'un 4 c'est
important pour être en paix avec
soi-même voyez moi mon cadre c'est ça
c'est les amis le logement le travail la
santé si je m'occupe pas de ma santé
alors évidemment vous allez me dire ça
c'est comme tout le monde du jour au
lendemain on a un cancer mais moi c'est
ma santé mentale donc jusqu'à la fin de
ma vie j'ai un traitement si je prends
plus ce traitement je peux plus
travailler si je veux plus travailler je
peux plus payer mon logement et si je
peux plus payer mon logement bah mes
amis ils vont me dire attends Elena on
t'a aidé pendant des années c'est bon
donc ce cadre tous les jours j'ai fait
très attention très attention vraiment
je le
mais j'y prends soin
ce que je voulais vous dire c'est que
on s'en fout que le cadre du voisin vous
plaise pas l'important c'est que vous
ayez votre propre cadre pour être en
paix avec vous-même mais en tout cas il
y a une chose que j'ai compris avec mon
demi-siècle passé c'est que sans cadre
on meurt
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup